the Deadpool movies looked a lot
different on set than what we saw on
screen the animators and VFX Specialists
worked overtime to bring us Larger than
Life characters like Colossus major
destruction sequences card chases
incredible superpowers and the entire
city we see on screen go get em tiger
big CGI fight coming up number one we
can't talk about Deadpool without
mentioning his mask we started sculpting
the mass even before we were awarded the
project it was that important to me to
get that right because that's everything
they start with a digital scan of Ryan
reynolds's face and then they sculpt on
top of it
so many little subtle things how tall
the head is how skinny the jawline is
the shape of the eyes after sculpting it
with Clay they digitize it and then 3D
print it we have to build things in
there so that you can breathe and the
sweat isn't causing a problem there are
even versions of the masks with
eyepieces that pop out there's a release
mechanism button in the back push it
pull the eyes there are different types
of eyes for all of the different stunts
that are performed number two not a
great scene for the X-Force
this sequence was shot with a
combination of the real actors for
close-ups and CG doubles for Far Away
shots did you notice Brad Pitt's Cameo
what was shooting that life
pretty much easiest thing I've ever done
fun fact the director of the movie David
Leach used to be Brad Pitt's stunt
double starting in Fight Club and going
all the way until 2004 before becoming a
director Mr Dave Leach here was hired as
my stunt double another fun fact is Brad
Pitt's payment for performing his
two-second Cameo was a cup of coffee
hand delivered to him by Ryan Reynolds
number three what a sight to see why
wouldn't you cover that up a warrior has
nothing to be ashamed of one thing that
made this performance pretty great was
that they actually used Ryan reynolds's
legs they thought if his legs were
restricted in any way it might affect
his body language he's dressed normally
from the waist up but has a motion
capture suit on from the waist down they
also had him walk on his knees as that
made him the perfect height for the
toddler legs he was sporting the only
thing he had to worry about was leaning
too far back or forward when taking each
step number 4. you guessed it all CGI
they decided to use a motion capture
suit for Cable's arm because they didn't
like how restricted the design would be
if they decided to go practical with the
digitally rendered version they'd be
able to change the look or remove his
arm easily if they needed to his neck
and chest area though was a combination
of both Prosthetics and CGI number five
what is Deadpool without a car chase
it's pretty obvious but this sequence
was filmed on a Sound Stage because of
that they were able to do a bit more
practically than they would have
otherwise CGI was still used to create
the other cars the environment and of
course when cable jumps out of the
exploding truck number six we've got a
dark Phoenix crossover here did you know
that this scene never actually happened
in real time it was all done with CGI
the production team of Deadpool 2 sent
the camera lens info and line up data to
director and fellow producer on Deadpool
Simon kinver he was the director of dark
Phoenix so while filming that he got a
perfect shot of the mutants that matched
the camera angle and Lighting on
Deadpool 2. thus making it super easy
for Wade to be superimposed right on top
of it did you know that was a CGI shot
when you first watched it number seven
did you know Ryan Reynolds is also the
voice of the Juggernaut an actual actor
wasn't needed to play him but they did
need a few lines for his character I'm
gonna rip you in half now so they
thought it best to use Ryan Reynolds
instead of bringing in a new actor
though they just used a motion capture
suit on a static Juggernaut model they
purposely modeled his facial expressions
after director David Leach number eight
a lot of that was actually practical the
program Houdini was used for the more
complex shots like intestines but for
the scene where Deadpool cuffs his own
hand they used actual buckets of fake
blood oh my God nasty oh there's the
money shot baby they used two buckets
for that sequence Alone number nine It's
All Digital there was a lot of green
screen usage in the making of Deadpool
they wanted the city to be a mix of
Vancouver Detroit and Chicago so the
animators broke the city up into 12
sections in order to pull off whatever
they needed for a specific shot the
director Tim Miller is also an animator
so that really helped with bringing his
vision of Deadpool to life there were
over 1200 difficult shots that needed to
be captured strictly with the magic of
Animation you're just trying to
replicate reality through a different
medium and you have to pay closer
attention to reality in order to
replicate it in CG number 10 is this a
good time for a piccolo reference though
definitely not as seamless of a
regeneration Deadpool's limbs take time
to grow back the shot of his tiny hand
was achieved with a digital limb it was
tricky because it couldn't be like a
baby hand because a baby hand doesn't
actually look like that it needed to be
a fetus hand they were sending us this
horrible reference of fetuses but it was
so we could get that translucency right
number 11. let's talk about negasonic
teenage Warhead unsurprisingly those
Powers were all CGI but started off as
just concept art they wanted something
that looked like solar flares coming
straight from the sun when it came to
the final sequence at the end of the
first film negasonic teenage Warhead
uses Deadpool like a fuel air bomb that
sequence was shot entirely with the
green screen and then they filled in the
explosion with animation number 12. they
used rotting fruit and maggot eating
meat as a reference they built tumorous
effects as textures and then digitally
rendered the layers to map them onto a
digital model before creating the 3D
topology the more the compositor was
getting grossed out from his own work
the more I knew we were closer to a
final number 13
remember when Wade first faces off
against Francis the only reason he was
able to escape his asphyxiation pod was
by setting the whole place of flame that
fire was a combination of practical set
pieces that were lit aflame as well as
digital Renditions their biggest
struggle was trying to make the fire
look layered and not flat against the
building so the creative Direction they
went was to not make the building look
like it was being engulfed By Flames but
more like it was falling apart number
14. it took five actors to create
Colossus the first performer captured
his movements during a motion capture
studio session but there was also a
separate six foot nine inch performer
filmed on location in our classic gray
tracking suit they still wanted him to
be taller so he either had to wear
platform shoes or an extra headpiece for
height colossus's face was modeled after
a third actor because of his jawline
while a fourth performer recorded all of
the dialogue and a fifth performer was
used strictly for facial animations the
animators get to tweak and refine this
performance and adjust it for the kind
of deliberately solid metallic look
number 15. freeway Chase but
the freeway in the first Deadpool film
they had a difficult time finding a
freeway they could use to pull off the
insane stunts involved in the chase it
ended up being too much of a hassle so
the solution was to use vehicle
Interiors in front of a green screen
while utilizing multicam freeway plate
shots in Detroit and then constructing
the freeway and the other cars digitally
real freeway or not it definitely made
for an epic car chase
so we've got toddler legs regenerated
limbs the Juggernaut some incredible car
chases and some explosives going on in
these movies that combined with the
brilliant Prosthetics and practical
effects make Deadpool one of the most
incredible comic book franchises on
screen what was your favorite CGI moment